Gandalf what is the background of this
strange wanderer where did he come from
and why is he meddling at everyone's
affairs let's dive into Gandalf's story
and see what sets him up for the
critical role he ends up playing
throughout the Hobbit and Lord of the
Rings Gandalf comes into existence at
the beginning of time he is a
supernatural entity created by author
Tolkien's Supreme Being eluveitie
eluveitie or himself moves to Arda
Tolkien's name for the world his stories
take place within and he's joined by a
host of other celestial beings like
himself called Anya all of this takes
place thousands upon thousands of years
before the Lord of the Rings during his
youth Gandalf is named oléron he lives
in the lands to the west of middle-earth
he spends a good deal of his time in
Lorien a heavenly land filled with
gardens lakes and rivers he also keeps
company with nienna
a valor or leader of the an yer who is
known for her association with grief and
sorrow Gandalf is drawn to the children
of Aluva Tarr the elves and men in
Tolkien's world and is always keen to
help them however he typically doesn't
reveal himself to them in his true form
instead choosing to communicate to them
through visions hence the name oléron
which is translated as fantasy or dream
in these stories the supernatural on ER
are the highest order of beings in
middle-earth they're broken into two
different groups the valour and the mire
the valor made up a fourteen Aneurin
cluding nienna are the kings and queens
that rule over creation in the name of
Aluva are the rest of the an yer
are a group called the mire in the book
unfinished tales
tokine refers to these creatures as an
angelic order it's not known how many
mire there are but several of them show
up throughout middle-earth history Saren
for instance is probably the most well
known Meyer the Balrog is another less
powerful example however while these two
are forces for evil there were many
other Meyer that fight for good
including Gandalf while he isn't as
impressive on the surface
the gray Wanderers great claim to fame
is that in the summer iliyan he's
referred to as the wisest of the mayer
an impressive trait in a group of mighty
immortal spirits as well as being the
wisest of the Meyer Gandalf is also a
wizard the wizard title is a bit of a
misnomer when compared to the modern
English definition of the work in
unfinished tales
tokine explains the difference Tolkien's
wizard is a translation of the elvish
word estar representing an order that
has eminent knowledge of the history and
nature of the world these wizards or
istari are distinct from the sorcerers
and magic peddlers typically associated
with the name in reality they're semi
divine beings there are five main
wizards in Tolkien's writings referred
to in the two towers as quite simply the
five wizards
however unfinished tales explains that
their total number is unknown and that
some may have visited regions beyond the
northwestern portion of middle-earth the
istari are technically angelic
supernatural beings from the glorious
West however a mire becomes a wizard
when they've voluntarily been wrapped in
a frail mortal body and this isn't just
putting on an appearance so they can
blend in with men and elves either their
bodies age and die just like the bodies
of humans it's made clear in unfinished
tales that the physical forms that the
Wizards take restrict their abilities
and result in quote dimming their wisdom
and knowledge and confusing them with
fears tears and weariness coming from
the flesh this restriction is a natural
side-effect of the Wizards purpose in
life the Wizards were created and sent
to middle-earth specifically to help
resist sauer because of this the simmer
alien says that they were forbidden to
simply overpower the Dark Lord with
godlike powers nor were they allowed to
dominate men or elves when in battle
while he's been around from the
beginning of time it turns out that it
isn't until well into the third age that
Gandalf is asked to take on his wizardly
form in unfinished tales the head of the
valour Mon Wei chooses Gandalf to become
the quote to
director and coordinator of attack and
defense however Gandalf resists the
nomination as he is afraid of saurons
power but man way insists explaining
that his wise caution is precisely why
he is perfect for the job the five main
Wizards are chosen and begin to arrive
on the western coast of middle-earth
approximately one millennium into middle
earths Third Age this roughly coincides
with the time Sauron begins to set
himself up in Mirkwood as the
necromancer we eventually meet in the
Hobbit trilogy according to one version
of the story Gandalf is the last istari
to arrive and it's said that he's very
unimpressive he's shorter than the
others already has gray hair and leans
on a staff in fact the text says that he
appears to be quote least of the now
mortal mire of the five wizards Gandalf
is obviously the most well known to
readers two others appear at times
throughout the Hobbit and Lord of the
Rings stories but the last two have no
active part in the narrative each of
these five representatives of the Valor
has different strengths but they weren't
meant to function as a team the most
impressive of the five Wizards is
Saruman known as the man of skilled he
is the first to arrive in middle-earth
he dresses in white which contrasts
boldly with his hair which is raven
black at first next up we have radagast
clad an earthen brown radagast is
interested in beasts and birds
last and certainly least as far as the
story goes are the blue wizards this
pair of Meyer dressed in sea blue
clothing are named Al Attar and Poland
oh and it's said that they traveled to
middle-earth as friends while having
five elite wizards wandering around
middle-earth it sounds like a great way
to fight back against Sauron it turns
out that the only member of the team
that genuinely has a net positive effect
is Gandalf
tokine refers to him as the only one who
remains faithful to his mission of
providing aid to the free folk sour
man's failure is well documented the
wizard becomes corrupt with power and
goes against the istari by dominating
others and actually trying to replace
Souren radagast --sf eight is quietly
tragic as the wizard slowly slips into
an obsession for birds and beasts rather
than elves and men fading into obscurity
the blue wizards are fascinating to
hard-core Tolkien fans because almost
nothing is known about them
tokine talked about them as if they were
a riddle that he didn't have time to
solve it said that the duo traveled far
into the east with Saruman but never
came back in 1958 Tolkien explained that
they may have founded far away cults
after failing the mission when Gandalf
first meets the shipwright seared on the
elven Lord immediately sees right
through the wizards lowly appearance and
recognises the important role that
Gandalf is going to play in the war
against Sauron this lead seer done to
give Gandalf a ring of power to help him
throughout his adventures no not the One
Ring of Power
but a powerful piece of enchanted
jewellery nonetheless Sirians gift is
narya the red one of the three elven
rings the ring is meant to help support
Gandalf through his labors and spark
courage and others while canned off
accepts the gift he attempted to keep it
secret however he's unable to conceal it
from sour man who becomes jealous over
the preferential treatment in fact
according to tofu this is the event that
begins to erode the friendship between
two wizards when the five wizards arrive
in middle-earth the events of The Hobbit
and The Lord of the Rings are
roughly 2,000 years in the future so
what does Gandalf do to kill the time
turns out we don't know his name rarely
appears in the history of this lengthy
period and he seems to have fallen off
the map for huge chunks of time
fortunately Tolkien gives us a little
hint and unfinished tales what he says
probably he wandered long and various
guises engaged not in deeds and events
but in exploring the hearts of elves and
men who had been and might still be
expected to be opposed to Souren in
other words he spends a lot of time
wandering all over the West lands of
middle-earth generally laying low making
friends and increasing his understanding
of the lay of the land he doesn't settle
down at all during this point either
remember he's known as the grey wanderer
or the gray pilgrim with so many
centuries of wandering under his belt
it's natural that Gandalf would acquire
many nicknames the name Gandalf means
the elf of the wand since men thought he
was an elf Tolkien himself admitted that
he got that one directly out of Norse
mythology beyond that the wandering
wizard reveals in the two towers that
quote many are my names in many
countries we've already heard of Alura
his name in the West at the beginning of
time
the elves also call him Mithrandir which
means the gray pilgrim adding to the
list of monikers the dwarves call him
Thor [ __ ] which translates to staff man
he also says that in the south he's
called in Kaunas however Tolkien himself
seemed to be unsure about how to explain
this last one in one note he says that
it comes from the horrid dream language
and meant alien or North spy however in
later notes he claimed that it was just
a common name for the grave pilgrim in
Gondor one other important activity that
Gandalf participates in prior to Lord of
the Rings is befriending hobbits Gandalf
is the only wizard who sees the value of
the halflings making a distinct effort
to cultivate a deep connection with the
agricultural community of the Shire he
also entertains the shire folk whenever
possible establishing a reputation for
his incredible fireworks magic tricks
an excellent storytelling on the
flipside he also gets a bit of a bad rap
throughout their tranquil community for
convincing many quiet Hobbit
lads and lasses to run off into the blue
format Adventures a thousand years after
Gandalf's arrival he visits the fortress
of Dumbledore in southern Mirkwood where
Souren has been rebuilding his power
the wizard drives the Dark Lord out
leading to the centuries long period
called the watchful peace Gandalf
also serves as a member of the Council
of the wise or the white Council it's
composed of Saruman
Galadriel and Elrond among others
gandalf actually leads this prestigious
body at one point but later leaves and
the physician is awarded to his fellow
wizard sour man instead at one point
gandalf searches for the missing dwarven
King Thorin the second in his search he
journeys through Moria and then revisits
still Ghidorah here he finds a dwarf who
gives him a map and a key for the Lonely
Mountain
he also finally discovers that the
necromancer has returned and is just
Souren in disguise he urges the white
council to attack while their enemy is
unprepared the council eventually
attacks in defeat salad at which point
Gandalf withdraws to Mordor as we get
into the events of The Hobbit
Gandalf's backstory is drawing to a
close at this point we find Gandalf in
unfinished tales writing to the Shire
for a sabbatical as he nears the end
called the Prancing Pony
he Ponder's the impending evil threats
scattered throughout middle-earth
suddenly he encounters Thorin
Oakenshield the Dwarven hero is also
deep in thought as he travels in exile
thanks to Smaug the dragon who has taken
up residence in his mountain home half a
world away the two began to talk and
Gandalf decides to visit the dwarfs new
home after further discussion the wizard
heads to the Shire to contemplate
not long afterward he hears about the
eccentric Hobbit Bilbo Baggins whom he
hasn't seen since Baggins was a child he
starts making a plan and the rest is
middle-earth history check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
classic fantasy are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]